[Applause]
good morning Hank it's Friday you know
who's in my hub bucket grease every time
I see grease I just want to give him a
big ol hug I don't tell everyone and
give them 150 billion euro and therein
lies a problem okay so I don't want to
talk about sovereign debt today but just
to establish at the outset that this is
not a particularly political problem
here's a chart of the gross federal debt
by President as a percentage of GDP as
you will notice the fluctuations have
nothing to do with whether the president
is blue or red the same is true in other
developed countries as well okay so I
have to begin let me tell you one of the
great rules of economics if you are rich
you have to be an idiot not to stay rich
and if you are poor you have to be
really smart to get rich this is true
for individuals but it's also true for
countries Fancy Pants countries with
Fancy Pants currencies have all kinds of
advantages over developing countries
including that we are able to borrow
money cheaply in fact because Fancy
Pants countries can borrow money so
cheaply it actually often makes sense to
run a deficit and the reason for this is
that in the long term our economy can
grow faster than the cheap cheap debt
were acquiring to pay for our economy to
grow so debt is not inherently bad for
nations the famous example of this is
that in 1945 the United States had a
debt that was more than a hundred
percent of its GDP and our deficit was
more than twenty percent of our GDP and
that level of debt immediately preceded
the largest expansion of our economy in
history also the largest expansion of
our waste lines in history yes that's
funny we did get that so debt is not bad
but debt that you can't repay is very
bad the trick of Fancy Pants countries
being able to borrow money cheaply has
always been that the market assumes that
fancy-pants countries are basically
guaranteed to pay you back and when I
say the market assumes I mean the market
assumed until two months ago when it
realized that Greece a fancy-pants
country with a fancy-pants currency
maybe can't pay back its debts what's
interesting is that Greece is probably
technically in a better economic
position that America was back in 1945
but for a variety of reasons some of
them very legitimate the market is
decided that Greece won't be able to pay
back its debt which in turn has led to
new debt being much more expensive which
has in turn made it completely
impossible for Greece to ever pay its
debt you see Hank it's a circle and it's
vicious that's what they got the term
this raises the possibility that
fancy-pants countries with fancy-pants
currencies might not pay back the money
we loan them
which will probably raise interest rates
for a lot of fancy-pants countries which
could lead by the vicious circle two
more defaults higher interest rates more
defaults higher interest rates I could
go on like this forever which would be
very bad like we would yearn for the
days of 10% unemployment all which is
complicated by the fact we're coming out
of a worldwide recession and the total
economic output in the world is smaller
so there is less money coming in in
taxes but governments still need to
spend approximately the same amount of
money and for everybody who says that
the problem is wasteful government
spending we are even close to a balanced
budget I mean the United States would
have to eliminate both of its two
biggest expenses social security and
defense in order to even come close to
balancing the budget the only other way
to shrink the deficit would be to raise
taxes which is not generally seen as a
good idea during a recession so the
problem of sovereign debt maybe not
being as cheap as it once was isn't the
fault of any one political ideology it's
kind of everybody's fault so basically
Hank I don't want to alarm you but I do
think we should all buy unicorn pinatas
and hide our valuables in them
absolutely Hank the unicorn strategy
won't work because we have to keep
loaning each other money and we have to
figure out a way to loan confidently
like we did back in 1945 that's why the
EU and the IMF are working so hard to
try to nail down a bailout plan for
Greece and if fancy-pants countries
can't continue to convince us that our
money is as safe with them as it is
inside of a unicorn pinata they will
lose the cheap money privilege they have
enjoyed for centuries and history tells
us that once a stupid rich man gets poor
he doesn't usually get rich again unless
he is Donald Trump Hank I'll see you on
Monday
see you on Monday that's our signal to
stop watching but nerdfighters there is
still time to participate in our secret
project click here for more info here I
made it a heart for you click